I want to lighten things up a little bit
you know it's we're dealing with some
dark subjects and we got a really dark
subject in in a bit but let's let's uh
let's let's start with something that's
going to give everybody a good laugh
Here We Go From The Guardian Twitter
sued for disproportionately firing
female workers after musk buyout the
proposed class action lawsuit alleges
that after the Takeover 57 of women were
laid off compared with 47 percent of men
the reason why I say that's funny is
because there's that Meme where Elon
Musk he did this he sent an email saying
will you make the pledge to work hard
yes or no if no I you will be laid off
and get three month Severance and then
this data comes out where there are like
57 percent of the people who get laid up
for women so at first I understand Elon
Musk did laugh a bunch of people
immediately without question but then he
came back with that who wants to work
hard and who doesn't so you've got a few
things here is it that ten percent uh
proportionally more women were like I
would not want to work hard there's an
article from The Washington Post that
says Elon musk's vision of working late
hours at the cost of sleep family and
friends is retrograde and it was like
it's like written by a woman and I'm
just kind of like
you know the sound the idea of working
16 hours a day at the cost of all those
things is appealing to me is there is
there something where there's like a
difference between men and women on this
one we know that women tend to be
subject-oriented men tend to tend to be
object oriented is that the cause of
this or is there just a simple there
were more women working in comms and
more comms people got fired there were
more men working in engineering so less
of them got fired or something like that
it's that Meme you know what I mean
where uh before Twitter it's all women
and then after it's all men
or you guys think Elon sexist
what do you think
I I don't have a funny answer to it but
I would probably just say that 57 or a
good percentage maybe cared about that
they had that uh disamplification or
disenhancement you know they were taking
away visibility from people that did
they didn't agree with and they simply
were just saying okay if elon's gonna
take over and if he's not going to
censor these beliefs that we don't agree
with I don't want to work for that
company and and it's not that big of a
margin what is it 57 I mean how do you
quantify that especially when it's you
know a few hundred people what was that
a few thousand people well I mean here's
the issue too there were more men
working for the company than women so
this means more men got fired than women
but when you compare only men to men and
women to women then the percentages make
it seem like more women got fired yeah
this feels like it's just a frivolous
lawsuit meant to entangle Elon Musk and
to stop him from doing other things and
to drain away his resources uh that's
just my initial reaction to this I could
be wrong but I highly doubt a lot lot of
the decisions were based off sexist
Decisions by Elon Musk to me there's no
evidence showing that at all and it's a
ridiculous claim in my opinion yeah I
find um I don't know there's a tendency
for men to be more obsessed with Science
Tech and things and women to be more
obsessed with people and like things
like that especially when it comes to
coding especially when it comes to
development sitting in a building for 16
hours without a shower and stinking is
I'm okay with it I do that almost every
day in fact I like it
um but I most women I know like to be
clean especially because they need to be
clean for health reasons cleaner than
men well it's not just that but but
predominantly men like to of course be
Engineers like to build and develop
women like to organize women like to
keep things orderly not always but but
more generally speaking that's the case
here and when we look at the jobs at
Twitter they're going to be not doing
what they did before they're going to be
developing essentially what is the next
WeChat here in the United States and
encompassing everyday life which is
going to include a lot of coding a lot
of hard engineering work in order to
develop the app of everything the X app
as Elon Musk has called it so that's not
going to attract a lot of people who
aren't going to be able to tell people
what to say and what to think and to
Shadow them because they can't do that
anymore I think there's a lot of
administrative bloat at Twitter a bunch
of middle management and maybe they were
more women in middle management maybe
there were more guys I mean we saw the
videos they're like oh yeah we got free
wine I know we're gonna go on the roof
and we're gonna hang out no if you have
adopt that right now and then and then
obviously retrograde I want wine and
Legos yeah I guess it depends on what
you want to do with your tech company
but I find like you want about 90 of
your employees to be programmers I don't
know maybe that's a little off base I
have only run one tech company I didn't
really run it myself I helped run it but
remember what was it Polly Pocket you
remember that thing yeah what was the
dude version maximum Mighty Max Mighty
Max was that what it was I was all about
it yeah and it was like you had a little
thing you'd open it and get a little
game and then the girl version was the
Polly Pocket you know maybe I'll throw
I'll throw a bone to the left
people Millennials were socialized very
very differently young women play with
different toys than young boys and that
leads them to be very different when
they're older that's going to have an
impact on how people want to work in
their jobs the way they're raised that
that I will say all right so at the very
least that could be the case I'll also
say one of the tricks that they that the
left uses is they turn the out the the
obvious and overt differences between
men and women into racism misogyny
discrimination Etc or I should say in
this instance misogyny returned to
sexism if uh women need more sick days
than men for you know health reasons you
will then see if you look at I I'd be
willing I I'd be willing to bet but I
could be wrong I'm interested to see do
women take off more sick leave than men
what do you guys think more time I would
imagine just if if raising families is
involved but that's not super common no
no sick leave just take days getting
sick and having a hard time working you
think I don't know men or women more
likely to I don't know for sure but my
my personal view is like I bet women
would because women have health issues
and I got no issue with that but imagine
if I then went into the directory and
said for some reason all of these women
are abusing the Health Care System
certainly it's what's going on right men
and women are are different the the
genders are bimodal it means there's two
big bell curves they overlap greatly but
there are some differences if this means
that women overwhelmingly work in comms
and Men overwhelmingly work in
engineering then when the layoffs come
and they say we're laying off
Communications and it disproportionately
affects women they then ignore that fact
of the differences between men and women
and say ah the fact that you find more
women proves that he's a sexist and it's
in its illegal discrimination but in
reality you don't need a huge bloated
comms unit in a tech company I don't
think so they are obviously I guess when
you get to the level that Twitter's at
you become a bit more of a
Communications Department than you are
when you're a startup Tech platform
because the government wants to come
talk to people and have you have
Departments of people they're doing
Communications and stuff so maybe I
could see that changing but you know for
the benefit of the good of the the
future of the work I don't think you
need massive comms you know I was right
according to the Department of Labor
women take around 32 days I think uh is
per year and men take 25. huh they got
ovaries yeah well quite frankly from the
very people that have been censoring us
and there was no rationale behind it
there was no policy that actually
you know said that's what we were doing
I have trouble believing the very people
that were lying about the reasons why we
were censored in the first place that
they are being discriminated against to
begin with and quite frankly I mean I
don't I don't think I have sympathy for
them you know it's kind of like when CNN
is laying off people certainly I don't
want anybody to be out of a job and not
be able to provide for their family but
it's like if you've been maligning us
and doing horrible things to us that I'm
not sure I have sympathy for you when
you are losing your job I got more data
in terms of General leave just not even
sick women take uh what is it 34 days
versus men's 21 days that's interesting
twice as much and it says primarily they
take longer leaves for a new child women
take 54 days versus men taking 18. but I
totally get it like I don't I don't
expect a guy to take 54 days he didn't
birth this child you know I think women
would just I think women deserve that
time off I think men should get a good
amount of time off to be with their kids
don't get me wrong but I mean that's
just biological differences it's going
to manifest in various ways they want
more time off what if Elon went in and
said fire anybody who took more than 30
days off this year he didn't say
anything about women
but that would get rid of more women
than men right
are these uh full-time employees that I
see it down here at the bottom it says
uh 3700 or are these full-time employees
are these people they're working one day
a week I'd be curious to see the those
numbers I don't know if they have them
but I think a lot of people were
considered full-time but we're remoting
in and we're like you know just doing
bare minimum and that's part of elon's
issue with it it blows my mind to think
that if an owner of a company comes in
is like someone's doing a patch up like
you're doing a bad job I've given you
some warnings you're fired and they're
like you're firing me because I'm white
I'm like no I'm firing you because you
suck get out no it's because I'm tall
you're firing me because I'm a woman
because I'm black like dude you suck at
your job get out end a story why do you
get to pick social politics and bring
that into it I don't get it I don't get
it well the woke people live in this
world where everything is based on race
or identity
instead of looking at
you know instead of looking at the data
and being like hmm I wonder I wonder why
more women take time off nope nope it's
it's discrimination you know I bet there
are situations where it's not a cop-out
so I shouldn't speak all for all time
but there are many many times when I
think the best the worst people will get
fired and it has nothing to do with your
identity it's purely because of your
ability
or or because you just your position
isn't needed anymore you know you got to
be so good that the company needs you
you got to make your position so
valuable that the company can't run
without it I mean that's one way to do
it the left wants companies to keep on
bad employees because of the employee's
identity
that just that just doesn't work it's
good on paper yeah well you know and
then you get bridges that collapse and
stuff like that you should see the laws
that they have in California when it
comes to boards and uh their regulations
there which is again absolutely insane
but I you know there's a lot of data
suggesting that you know men do work
more days in a year on average than
women do does this have an effect here
maybe I think so I think this cycle has
happened a lot in history and what I
don't want to happen is for it to become
where people resent let's pick women for
instance or some sort of class of human
a female white black you know whatever
that people because the job the
companies start to suffer because
they're forced to have a certain amount
of women and a certain amount of men and
maybe it doesn't matter their
qualifications that people will start to
resent those people those under
qualified people that got the position
on identity and then if the system
really falls apart there's going to be
massive amounts of resentment and then
you'll start over with this really like
extreme system where people are like
women aren't the women people have
actually joked about repealing the 19th
Amendment because they're so frustrated
with this stuff wait wait what do you
mean joked yeah exactly it's not if some
people haven't even joked they just say
it's maybe we should strip women's right
to vote because they're so pissed off
women being forced into positions
they're not qualified for for identity
purposes what what is a woman Ian
good question Tim good question so I
tweeted that um now that we know that
biological sex isn't real we should
repeal the 19th Amendment because it's
become redundant
right I'm telling you well why would you
need it if biological sex isn't real the
19th Amendment specifically says the
right to vote shall not be uh in you
know Abridged or whatever or whatever
the word is uh so you can't it says sex
specifically says sex that the right to
vote will not be stopped because of your
sex but if the left's position is that
biological sex doesn't exist anymore
well then we don't need the 19th
Amendment everybody agrees no no
seriously if they if if so that's the
first question I have you go to you go
to conservatives like you know Milo or
whatever he says outright you know
repeal the 19th Lydia she says repeal
the 19th and it's like okay well you
know like I personally don't agree with
that but I'm also not somebody who
thinks biological sex uh doesn't exist I
think it does so then fine here's my
pitch to Milo and to Lydia go to
leftists and say is biological sex a
real thing when they say no be like okay
would you like sign this position to
repeal the 19th Amendment which
specifically grants voting rights based
on sex that's that's transphobic isn't
it okay great then when they sign it
there you go get your petitions get your
your your two-thirds of States Article
Five convention or whatever and then you
can repeal the 19th but the reality is
men and women are different they have
women have ovaries genetically sexually
or different Creations you know maybe
gender is a conversation is worth having
that people have different you know
gender identities whatever but
biological sex is very real it's very
real we're all born of a woman as far as
I know all of us here probably were you
guys I was I had a mom and a dad sperm
in an egg female and a male they work
together you sound like a bigot how dare
you express these opinions I mean I have
to disavow immediately
um Scott do you disavow Ian
absolutely thank you not yes
uh okay good I think a lot of times
personalities get labeled as gender
identities too and it's just like people
are different men and women are
different people are different we all
come from different backgrounds
different cultures and there's too often
people are trying to put you in a little
box say this is what you are and it's
just like yo be an individual you know
dude that's awesome thinking of it as a
personality trait difference instead of
a gender differ it doesn't have to be
gender just because your personality
feels like something
yeah that's a good point well it's just
so ironic you know because they're
they're looking for these immutable
characteristics as diversity but they
won't include diversity of thought of
ideology of religion that's too much
that's too much we got to keep it
superficial here you know so they they
took the video down it was it was a
debate between Jordan Peterson and this
professor the video is now unavailable
but the quote was
basically it's not correct that there is
such a thing as biological sex uh he
said I'm a historian of medicine I can
break that down in great detail but for
the purpose in the sake of time I won't
and uh it was a Jordan Peterson having a
debate on gender so and this is 2016. if
that's the position they want to take I
mean man that's six years ago six years
ago this is a long time that means a 12
year old who was not paying attention to
politics back then is voting now that's
crazy and they don't think that
biological sex exists all right well
then the 19th Amendment doesn't need to
exist either
I think it's okay that biological sex
exists it's so weird when people
conflate sex and gender too I don't like
that the sex thing is just like
blatantly real sex is real like male and
men and women are both here together I
gotta say though I I don't see how they
argue themselves away from that one the
19th Amendment explicitly says on the
basis of sex if they don't think it
exists then what is the basis for the
19th Amendment
simply put ask them ask your Lefty
friends calmly and do you think we
should have a 19th Amendment yeah the
one that you know what that does it
affirms in the Constitution that
biological sex is real that that's
transphobic right well then we gotta get
rid of it
it doesn't necessarily affirm because
there could be zero women
and the 19th Amendment could still be
there just wouldn't be affecting anyone
so what they see that could be a
situation where they're like hey there
are no Sexes so let's repeal the
redundancy and then all of a sudden
they're like actually there are Sexes
you guys are gonna have to work to get
an Amendment of the Constitution to get
to vote again like no no no no
everyone's able to vote now that's hey
look if they want to remove their own
right to vote then people can vote away
their right to vote I guess thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time